il est notre invité ce soir je vous le
dis il fait son grand retour
son nouvel album pyramide sort bientôt
son single des planètes est disponible
depuis ce matin il est déjà numéro 1 du
top titres itunes il est avec nous ce
soir
notre invité est là
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te dire quoi faire dépenser en tant
que document sont encore grave tu dois
faire ta peau contre matt hall est
contre alors ça part de là tu vois ça
part de là laisse comme cela c'est
d'accord là comme ceci j'ai vu des gens
faire ça non là je dis non c'est comme
ceux ci sa part de la fda et
entreprenante avenir en tant que corps
et dans la vérité au nom d'un grand will
deal et pédro et allahou mais oui vous
avez si je suis très très animé le taux
de faire tout ça et là le dvd collector
ça tu pars avec mad max le signer mais
est ce qu'on peut se quitter sur cette
année là avec matt avec jérémy tu
connais la chorégraphie ou pas alors tu
so what
les faits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à des bonbons
vient un problème assez mal d'amour
merci
je te cramer
mais là